a tour of the villages and towns north
of kiev where russia is accused of
committing war crimes
starting in borrow dianka where u.n
secretary general antonio guterres saw
for himself the scale of devastation
there is no way a war can be acceptable
in the 21st century look at that
borodianka like so many towns was
occupied by russian forces and nearly
flattened by their onslaught ukrainians
say mass graves there are proof that
russian forces are committing atrocities
then to bucha where bodies of civilians
were found with hands tied behind their
backs earlier this month when ukraine
recaptured it from russian forces
and to charred residential towers in
urpin where there's been extensive
damage
innocent civilians were living
in these buildings
they were paying
the highest price
for a war for which they are not
contributed at all
ukrainian officials were frustrated he
visited russian president vladimir putin
in moscow before kiev
zielinski called it ambiguous to see the
aggressor before the victims the u.n
secretary general has been unable to get
the sides to see eye to eye but wants to
begin the negotiation process to stop a
war that many ukrainians had hoped the
un would prevent in the first place
andrew chappelle al jazeera
well on the battlefield ukraine says
russia has increased the pace of its
offensive in the east there's been
fierce fighting in the donbass region
russian forces have taken these two
towns in the east they're pushing
towards the cities of lehman and papas
now on the front line defended by
ukrainian troops and satellite imagery
from mario pole is revealing the damage
done by russian shelling on the azov
stall steel plant that's where ukrainian
soldiers and civilians are sheltering
russia has continued its airstrikes on
the facility despite agreeing in
principle with the un to allow
evacuations
thousands are hiding in the steel plants
underground tunnels as russian forces
surround the city
and at least one person has been killed
in car keefe and another two injured
after russian shelling on a residential
area on wednesday
emergency crews went to the scene to
treat the wounded and put out a fire
ukraine's second largest city has faced
shelling nearly every day since the war
began
let's get the latest on the situation in
the east of ukraine and bring in charles
stratford he's joining us from lehman
that's in the donbass region charles
update us on what you're hearing and
seeing
hi there yes you join us north east of
the city of slavansk
a few kilometers away from a contested
town called lehmann that we've been
reporting on
about a lot in recent days now we were
in this area four days ago
and it seems as if quite a lot has
changed since in the last half an hour
or so we've heard a lot of incoming very
close
shelling um and outgoing
targeting positions we understand in the
forests to our left and right
uh the the military here very nervous
they've moved us on
once and we've just been had to
basically negotiate pretty hard to get
you this picture i'm seeing a lot of
smoke
in in the distance there now
lee man is hugely important because it
is part of russia's wider campaign to
surround the city of slovansk and
further south krematorsk
it's going on here and it's also going
on in various other positions to the
west of me
um the road that leads up to a city
called isiam
which the russians control they have
been repeated attempts by the russian
military to push down
that road the m30 it is from isiam
towards slavyansk so far the ukrainian
military have held them back
in the last 24 hours or so the ukrainian
military reporting that there has been a
move even further west to that of isiam
again trying to pull round to slavyansk
uh basically savants can cremators two
of the largest urban areas still under
full ukrainian control
and so there is a huge focus as you can
imagine from the russian forces in
trying to encircle them and trap
many ukrainian forces in this area it's
a similar scenario and i heard you
mention it in the intro a town called
popassna
now we were relatively close to that
town earlier today again a lot of
shelling there a lot of black smoke
we think we may have seen we know there
have been evacuation attempts from
remaining civilians in what we
understand is to be a pretty much
destroyed city now uh or town now half
of it we understand controlled by the
russians half controlled
by the ukrainians and that again is a
move pop-up is east of here a move in
this direction there have been a lot of
moving parts in the last 24 hours it's
fair to say that this all indications
would suggest that there is a concern
effort by the russians to try and take
more territory and they are doing that
but at a very slow pace
there's also interesting move from the
south the south west of russian
controlled territory a move towards the
city of zaparishna there are reports of
russian troop movements heading towards
zaparishna that is just south of dunipro
a town that has not been a city a huge
city that has not
had the heavy kind of shelling that
other cities have suffered in the last
couple of months although
according to the ukrainian military
there was a residential area that was
hit earlier this morning in zaparisia at
least three civilians injured in that
um and just one uh last
salient piece of news certainly in the
last hour or so
around the area of trotsky an area that
we were in yesterday that had been
shelling there in the morning there'd
been a number of civilians injured in
that shelling today we've heard that
that shelling has continued at least
three civilians killed in that area
so it certainly seems as if as i say
there seems to be a concerted effort by
russian forces according to military
analysts trying to capitalize on some of
this good weather that we're beginning
to see in ukraine now that the ground is
uh is beginning to dry up and the and
the skies are clearer um certainly this
second phase as the the the russian
military are calling it is very much
underway and this area that we're in at
the moment very much the focus of of
their attention okay thank you that is
what's happening on the ground in the
east of ukraine charles stratford
reporting from lehman